Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Yes, I sound very, very, very weird.
If you guys were not there for the Twitch stream earlier today, I am currently traveling at the moment.
So I am at a... I am not at my usual setup.
As you guys know, I am streaming all of this on Wi-Fi on my laptop.
So, it's a little... I'm not used to it at all.
I'm not.
No, I am not on vacation right now.
I'm actually working.
This is very related.
For those who didn't see the special announcement, the very, very special announcement that was announced on Saturday last week, I am going to be at Anime Expo.
Yes!
Woo!
So, I will be at Anime Expo on July 4rd, which is the day before my birthday.
And as you guys can see here, it says, Doki Bird Birthday Celebration Concert.
Yes!
There will be a 3D concert on July 3rd.
So, okay.
So, I'll go into, like, more in-depth about everything.
So, next day, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Spilling us with Doe Kitty and Glasses.
Awesome.
Okay.
So, I'm going to go into in-depth about all of the stuff that's going on with it here.
But yes, first time watching stream... Oh my god.
That's an awkward moment.
Ha ha ha ha!
You're going to have, like, the scuffed audio as your first time watching.
Please, check my other VODs when I have my actual setup, please.
Ha ha ha!
Um, I didn't want to, you know, I was, like, I thought about, like, you know, I was, like, oh, do I, uh, um, oh, am I not synced up?
Ha ha ha ha!
No!
Am I not synced up right now?
Oh, no!
Okay, I don't, okay, give me a sec.
I will fix this.
Give me a sec, guys.
I disappear.
I don't know why I'm not synced up during Twitch.
Is it because of YouTube?
Is it?
Is it YouTube?
Okay.
Testing.
One.
Two.
Three.
Why am I not synced up?
I don't understand!
I was synced up on YouTube.
I'm on Twitch!
Okay.
Um, it was unsynced during, okay, I got this, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna reset everything.
Um, it might just be, like, it might just be, uh, I just might just, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Pop, pop, pop.
Okay, I'm synced up now.
Guys, don't worry, I'm synced up now.
Don't worry.
I'm synced up now.
Am I synced up?
Yeah.
I think so.
I can't tell anymore.
I... I think I'm synced up now, right?
Yes.
Okay.
There we go.
We're back to normal.
Okay.
So, Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will there be Bloodborne 2 announcement after the concert?
Oh my god, stick to the end and maybe you'll find out if Bloodborne is still gonna be up there.
It's slightly... Oh my god.
How is it slightly up?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I can fix this.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I know how to fix this.
Okay.
Alright.
Disconnect.
Now.
Connect.
Hello, hello, hello.
Testing.
One, two, three.
Okay.
I think I'm synced up again.
I...
Okay.
I'm back now.
Back and back again.
Alright, sound guys.
My sound guys.
Let me know if the audio is okay with the BGM.
Okay.
Anyway.
So, I am traveling and it's very related to concert preparations.
Um, so, uh... Okay, guys.
Don't, don't fuck with me.
I'm gonna think about it.
I'm gonna keep thinking about the sync issue.
Um, anyway.
Um, uh, Sejan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, I am currently, uh, I am currently traveling right now.
So, I'm using my Elgato travel mic instead of my usual mic.
Um, and I'm currently streaming on Wi-Fi right now.
So, uh, so, yeah.
That's, like, I, I thought about it.
I was, like, okay, do I take a couple of days off or do I stream?
And I really wanted to stream because, um, because, like, I don't want to take more days off because I've been taking so many days off.
So, I was, like, okay, I, I stream.
I'm gonna do, like, streams that aren't game intense, like, too intensive for my laptop because I still want to, um, I still want to, like, stream for you guys.
I still want to be there for you guys even though I have to do, like, my concert preparation and stuff.
So, I know it's sad that I'm doing Deltarune with this scuffed-ass setup.
It'll be, like, part one.
Deltarune where I sound really fucking off and everything.
Um, but then, like, Deltarune part two and then everything is, like, professional again.
I, and then, and then, and then, I don't know, I, I saw that.
It's a nice day of, nice day of fishing.
Ha ha!
Um, so, and I really wanted, I was, like, I just tried to pick games that, uh, that aren't super, like, intensive for my laptop itself.
So, um, so then that's why I chose those games.
But I hope that it doesn't... The one thing that worries me always is that I hope it doesn't deter, like, new viewers to watch.
It's like, oh, wait, what the fuck?
Why is your mic like that?
I'm not watching this.
Like... Like, I hope that doesn't deter anyone.
Even though, like, it's like a double-edged sword, not streaming versus streaming.
Because I'm like, oh, I don't have my usual setup.
But I do sound, like, really... Um, I love their channel.
I love Viva La Dirt League.
I love their shit.
I always watch their videos.
Um, so I was, like, super excited to try out their new game.
Um, but, like, I hope that doesn't deter new people from checking in.
Be, like, their first impression.
Being, like, what the fuck is wrong with her sound?
Oh my god!
And everything.
Especially... I feel bad.
I feel bad that I'm doing... I have a nice day for fishing and I'm streaming like this.
Like... But I was like, I'm sorry.
Like, your game is, like, pixel art.
And it doesn't seem like it's, like, you know, 50 gigabytes of shit.
And it doesn't seem like it's gonna take my, like, like, 50 gigabytes of RAM and 100% of my CPU.
I'm sorry.
Like, it was the perfect game to stream while I'm traveling.
Anyway, guys.
I do have to say that, um, I have played chapter one of, uh, Deltarune, um, when it first came out.
Like, when, like, Bark Nights might remember this.
I actually streamed, like, it was, like, it...
I remember when it very vividly.
It launched on midnight or some shit.
And then it launched on midnight and I went straight to streaming it.
It was, like, a surprise launch.
The very first time Deltarune chapter one ever launched back then.
Um, I actually streamed it with my... for my Bark Nights all those years ago for the first release of chapter one.
So, I don't remember much about chapter one, not gonna lie.
I remember the ending of chapter one.
I don't remember much of chapter one.
Um, I bet I just, like, vaguely, like, remember some bits of parts of it when I play it again.
So, I have played chapter one before.
So, I'm not, like, going in completely blind.
I've never touched the future chapters.
Only because, like, I wanted to wait until, like, it ended.
But then I was like, I don't know what to stream this week while I'm traveling.
So, I guess I'll stream Deltarune.
It's coming out anyway.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Okay, who remembers?
Yes, it was very... it was, like, six plus years ago, wasn't it?
Deltarune chapter one was six plus years ago, right?
Um, I'm pretty sure.
Uh, it was old, old.
Like, people have been waiting for, like, the newest chapters for a fucking long.
Yeah, 2018.
19, 20, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24.
Yeah, it's been seven years.
Holy fuck.
It's been...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Chapter one was seven years ago.
Holy, holy, holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
We've been waiting for chapter one for so long.
Um, Hacktuber model.
I think it was super chap.
Thank you.
Ha ha ha ha, Glenn.
Ha ha ha ha.
Um, now you guys gotta wait another seven years for chapter five and six.
Yay!
Yippee!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Anyway.
Um, okay.
Um, so...
Uh, I hope...
I hope they noticed me.
I hope Viva La...
I don't remember their full channel.
I'm sorry.
Like, I love your shows, but, like, your channel name is so long, so I always forget what it's called.
But, ha!
I just remember Viva.
I hope Viva notices me.
Woo!
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Viva La Dirt League.
Yeah, because I love their...
I love their videos.
And I love their...
Um...
Um, I love their videos and their shorts.
So, um, it'll be so cool if they saw me streaming the game and be like, Oh my god, who is this?
Because I love their stuff.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha.
Um, anyway.
Uh, what?
Anime Expo.
Okay, so, um, yes.
It was announced very, very last minute.
Um, because we found out very last minute that we were going to be part of Anime Expo.
Um, but I believe, like, Iron Mouse and I are both, like, the only VTubers invited as official guests, uh, for Anime Expo.
At first it was just Iron Mouse.
Uh, basically, like, they announced the panel with her and, um, C-Dawg.
And then, and then mine got announced right after.
I didn't even know Iron Mouse was going to be, uh, because, like, at first they told us what we were the only V, like, I was the only VTuber that was going to be, like, invited.
So, I think they also got in last minute because when they told me that, I was like, Oh my god.
Okay, so they gave me a panel spot at first and, um, so they gave me a panel spot and they told us, they told my staff team and I, I did not expect it, we did not expect it at all.
Like, uh, so we found out, literally during May, like, we found out we got a panel spot.
Um, it's now June, but that's how last minute it was.
I found out in May, like, that I got a spot at Anime Expo and they wanted to invite me as another guest.
So, um, I was very surprised, um, because I didn't expect it.
So, I found out in May and then I was like, I want to make it very special because, um, I was like, you know, Anime Expo, you guys don't know, Anime Expo is one of the biggest anime conventions in, uh, in America, in the U.S.
So, I realized that was an incredibly huge opportunity.
So, I didn't want to do just a panel because, you know, usually I just do a panel for conventions that I'm invited to, but a lot of, I heard that, like, a lot of, like, um, execs also go to, execs and representatives for different brands and different companies and stuff also go to Anime Expo.
So, I figured this was, like, a huge opportunity.
Because if you guys didn't know, even my Nendoroid was announced during Anime Expo.
So, I figured, like, this might be a huge opportunity to do something extra special because it's something, like, you know, um, there's so many, like, you know, a lot of well-known people around, um, what's the word called?
Around Conicreation that will be attending.
A lot of brands, a lot of companies will be there, and maybe they want to check out, like, oh, hey, there's a VTuber concert.
I've never seen a VTuber concert before.
Like, oh, yeah, I heard VTubers are being really popular.
So, I figured, like, this could be a huge opportunity to, like, market myself as well, especially since it is free admission, by the way.
So, um, I know there's, like, um, there's, like, other concerts going around, but, as well, but it's on venue.
This one is on, on venue.
So, it is at Anime Expo, and you do not have to pay extra for it.
There is just free admission.
So, you just get, just, as long as you have a ticket, uh, as long as you have a ticket for the convention, you'll be able to watch this concert.
You'll be able to enter, uh, the venue for it.
So, um, you don't have to pay anything extra.
Uh, you know, be like, oh, man, another VTuber concert.
I have to pay for it.
No, no, no.
It's free.
And so, um, that's why I decided to, uh, I decided to do a 3D concert.
Um, and because of the opportunity it presented, and I, like I said, it was incredibly last minute.
And now, now some of you guys are like, what about streaming tickets?
Why aren't you, uh, dual streaming it at the same time as the concert?
So, there's two reasons.
There's several reasons why I'm not doing streaming tickets for it.
Um, it's because, you know, the concert itself is, uh, free.
So, I was like, it's not fair to make you guys, uh, pay, uh, for a free concert.
So, and then the second reason why is that the 3D studio, I've reached out and contacted to, uh, produce the whole thing for me.
Um, they are doing it on a very limited time frame.
With more, only a little bit more than a month to complete everything.
Um, so, because of that, um, I wanted the YouTube upload.
I will be uploading it on YouTube, by the way.
Um, I'll be uploading the concert on YouTube for free.
So, it's not like it's gonna be gone forever.
Because some people are like, oh my god, I can't believe you're making exclusive to Anime Expo.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's gonna be free for everybody, um, later on.
The reason why I'm uploading it later is because I wanted the 3D studio to be able to refine and, like, improve the concert after it, after, after it's performed, sure, after it's performed in Anime Expo.
So, it's like, it's gonna be like, it's like, you know, like the Blu-ray edition for, like, anime episode, where, like, animators, like, redraw things and touch it up and, like, redo everything.
Like, not everything, but make it, like, a lot nicer looking than what it was like when it aired.
So, it's gonna be like that.
Cuz, cuz, obviously, we're doing it in, like, a very tight time frame.
So, because of that, that's why I'm not dual streaming it at the same time.
Because I don't want you guys to see how scuffed- like, you know, be like, you know, things are clipping and, and then, like, you know, when you're watching it live on Venue, you don't notice it.
But then if you're watching it, record it, and you're watching it on, on, like, digital platform and everything.
It's gonna, you're gonna notice it even more, you know?
No, I am gonna release the Doki Bird director's cut.
I'm not releasing the scuffed one.
Um, that's like, but, um, no, no, cuz then you guys can clip it and then make GIFs of it.
No, I spent my, it's my own money.
Um, Glenn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will the Phantom 3 concert get the same stream in and be uploaded fully?
That, I don't know.
I, I, um, that concert was produced by Oshisparks and not by me.
So, like, all those decisions are under their organization because Min and I were just contracted as performers.
Um, we weren't the organizers for it.
So, like, we don't know actually.
That's right.
We got, like, um, we got, like, the clips very late as well.
Um, because they were, like, very busy with other stuff as well as, like, um, the, this 3D, the 3D studio that was, uh, we used for that had, was also, like, incredibly busy as well.
Um, so that's why we got the clips very, very, like, late.
You know, when I got the clips, I instantly uploaded because, like, we waited so long.
I was like, fuck it.
I'm dropping it now.
Like, I was like, uh, fuck it.
We waited so long.
I'm ready.
I'll drop it now.
Um, so, like, that's not under me.
That's under, um, Oshisparks.
Um, so, like, I, I'm so sorry.
I don't know.
That's why for this concert, it's all organized and paid for by me.
Um, there's no, like, you know, outside sponsor.
There's no, like, outside organization that's working on this concert.
Um, I am producing and organizing all of this myself and paying for it all by myself.
So, like, actually, you guys are paying for it.
Your money, your money is paying for it.
Even, like, for, like, special guests and stuff like that.
Um, I, I'm paying for all of it, for my guests as well.
Uh, And I won't tell you guys how much it costs.
I feel like VTuber concerts, it's sort of like, I don't care about, like, telling you guys how much it costs, but I'll tell you guys how much it costs after the concert.
So, if it looks not good, if it's, like, pretty scuffed, I'd be like, shh, but if it looks amazing, if it looks amazing, I'll be like, yeah, guys, this is how much I invested, or we invested.
I'll be like, this is how much we all invested.
But, I found out how much a concert costs.
Okay, so, um, the 3D studio, uh, the 3D studio, I, uh, contacted.
Um, like, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I'm scared of here, how many— Ugh, shit!
Do you know that we could film it like the Phantom V concert?
I want to copy, uh, the scuff edition too.
Neppers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
You know, it's America .
I can't— I can say photos... you can take photos, But, like, it's America.
I don't know.
I cannot or cannot say anything regarding that.
But you can take photos.
Legally, I'll just be like, it's America.
You have your amendments.
Kush, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For the funds, thank you for the super chat.
Glenn, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Free concert?
Well, you know what?
Fuck you, Hanpei.
Anyway, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
So, like, you know, who's gonna... I'm not encouraging anything.
Legally, I am not encouraging anything.
But, like, who will stop you?
I don't know.
Anyway, um, what was I gonna say?
Oh, fuck, I already lost my train of thought.
Oh, yes, oh, yes.
The 3D studio.
So, it's not a Japanese 3D studio.
I'm actually, um, working with a 3D studio in, um, in China.
So, I got, I got contacts because, like, I debated on which 3D studio to work with, especially in the tight time frame.
Um, and I decided to go with a 3D studio in China because of Gacha Games.
Because, because, because of, because of Gacha Games.
And I've always felt, like, the motion capture and, um, um, the motion capture and the, just, like, you know, in, in general, just is very, very impressive.
Like, the animation and motion capture.
So, I decided to go to a Chinese, uh, motion capture slash 3D studio, um, for this.
And I really, I'll, I'll, I'll talk more about the studio, um, after the concert.
But I told them that if they do this concert really well, I will work with them for my 3D debut.
So, this is sort of like a test run, too.
Um, I'm, I'm sort of using it as, like, a little test run on, um, testing out various 3D studios and see how I feel about it.
Um, Rosie, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Here's my part.
I can't travel because work, but no, I'll be cheering you on.
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
I wish, I wish you guys knew about this earlier, but literally I found out about this last month, too.
I found out about this last month, too, so I couldn't let you guys know, um, um, earlier.
And, uh, and, like, you know, let you guys plan your travel trips and everything.
I'm really sorry.
I know some of you guys are like, I wish I knew this earlier so I could plan my travel dates.
But yes, it was very, very last minute.
BiteSize, thank you for the MagentaSoupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much, Doki, for uploading a concert for all of us that can't be there.
I also really hope you're able to sell the merch online.
Thank you for the MagentaSoupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Yes, there will be like... we will have an artist alley.
It was gonna be... I think it's either... I don't know if it's in the vendors or in...
It's not gonna be in Exhibitor, but it's either gonna be in vendors or artist alley.
Where we're gonna be selling merch themed around the birthday concert.
And also, like, Anime Expo merch as well.
Um, as a collaboration with, um, with one of the artists.
So, um, there will be... I'm not sure if the birthday merch...
The... because there will... well, of course there will be birthday merch, like...
Um, but that's separate from the concert birthday merch.
But there will be concert-themed birthday merch at Anime Expo.
Also, I'm just unsure if we're gonna be doing online sales for that.
I have to wait for my staff to let me know what's going on with that.
But I'll update you guys about it later, whenever I get information.
Um, as always, for Anime Expo, you can give me gifts and letters.
Um, at the concert or at the booth, basically.
So, um, obviously the funds from the merch will help as well as birthday merch and stuff.
So you guys want to support the concert and everything.
You're at the convention, you can buy some of the merch that's there.
Or, uh, you know, order online the actual birthday merch on July 4th.
That doesn't mean July 4th there's nothing special.
My birthday actually has a special stream that I've been planning for.
So, like, it's not like, you know, it's not like the birthday concert replaces, um...
Replaces, uh, the, uh, ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba the actual birthday stream.
The birthday concert was actually, like, so last minute...
Surprise!
We're gonna do that, too!
So it's like a bonus.
So I did have plans for something for my birthday.
So it's not like this was gonna take over my birthday in general.
This was, like, literally just, like, an appetizer, last-minute thing that came up all of a sudden.
So, that's basically it.
But I think that's all I want to really talk about about Anime Expo.
Like I said, there's, like, there's... oh, wait, actually, did my sound guy say anything?
Okay, sound guy said nothing about anything about these sounds.
So, I assume that sound is okay.
I assume sound is okay.
But, yes, I will say that... what was I gonna say?
I think the... okay, okay.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
The sound quality did not... oh, he said turn down BGM, like, oh.
Oops.
Wait, did he?
Oh, my God, my filter thing didn't work.
Oh, I did not see that.
Whoops.
Okay, let's turn down the BGM.
Oh, I'm sorry, guys.
Was the BGM that loud, Chad?
I'm sorry, I didn't notice.
Was it actually that loud?
Uh...
Was the... was the BGM that loud?
I turned it down, I think.
Did I turn it down?
Whoops.
Okay.
Alright, I turned it down.
A little.
Uh... It was fine.
Okay, it was in BGM.
It wasn't that loud.
A tiny bit.
Whoops.
Well, we did all that update and the BGM was too loud.
Oopsie.
No!
I taught for so long.
Sorry, my YTC filter, I didn't update it properly.
So, like, yeah.
I forgot to... I forgot to update it properly.
But sound people, if you want to update me about sound, We have to do Discord.
Uh...
We have to do Discord.
Because, um... I don't have the YTC filter on correctly, uh, to see it.
Uh, alright.
What was I gonna say?
Um...
Um... It was good.
You know, I'm anal about sound quality.
You guys know that.
Uh... What was I gonna say?
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Uh... I guess that's really it about, um, the 3D concert.
Uh...
But yeah, it was super last minute.
I have to do a dance practice.
And...
More traveling later.
I have to... I have to do more traveling later.
Um...
Leak the... No!
Why would I leak the guest?
Bye now later!
I think I might show a portion.
Um...
I might have to do... Uh...
Uh... I might show a little bit of the portion of the concert on my birthday.
So, like, um...
So, um... I will... So, like, you know, at least you guys get a little bit something.
Um... And then you... I'll show, like, a lit... Like, one song from the concert...
On my birthday before I upload the HD Blu-ray edition of the concert.
So, I'll give you guys that.
Uh... I'll... I'll...
I'll give you guys that as, like, a little treat.
Uh... Before the Blu-ray edition shows up on my channel.
But yeah, that's really it about what's going on for Anime Expo.
And how it's going for it.
So, I do hope everything looks nice.
The examples they showed me for like the concerts they produced looked really, really, really good.
Like, not concerts, but like, I guess like the 3D stuff they've done before on Billy Billy, looked really, for other VTubers, looked really, really good.
So I was like, ooh, you know?
I was like, ooh, well, well, well, well, well, well.
This seems like a good opportunity to work together.
Yay!
So I hope, I hope my concert looks just as good.
That's all I hope for.
That looks just as good as the examples they showed me.
Especially with the tight timeframe that they have.
But yeah, I've been like, bouncing around a lot, and been bouncing around a lot everywhere.
And just, oh my gosh, I'm all over the place.
I, like, my staff has been like, oh, remember to do this, remember to that.
And I'm like, I'm sorry, I'm working on the concert right now.
They're like, oh, remember, remember this, remember, you need to do it.
I'm like, I'm like, I'm sorry.
I'm, I'm literally traveling right now.
I have so little time.
I have time, I'm sorry.
Um, hee hee ha ha.
Yeah, we need two dokis.
But yeah, I do hope, for those who are traveling to Anime Expo, that you guys will enjoy the concert.
And the, the, like, and it's watchable.
That's my hope.
And, um, and then that looks good.
And when I, when I get the Blu-ray edition of it, that it also looks pretty neato as well.
Um, but yeah.
Um, and that, my singing won't be that bad.
I hope.
Um, Glenn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Does the Blu-ray come with bloopers?
I don't know.
Maybe, maybe I'll show bloopers and stuff.
Like, and, um, extra recorded stuff.
Like, on, after the concert.
After it, I upload the, maybe after the concert, maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll show, like, extra recorded goodies and stuff after the concert.
Or, like, on the birthday stream.
And I'll show you guys that, maybe.
But, yeah.
Oh, yes.
The 3D upload of Last Cup of Coffee came out as well for Mint and I.
I'll tweet about that, too.
I'm sorry.
My social media stuff is, like, all over the place as well.
Like, I'm all over the place in general.
I need to tweet out about it.
I did not tweet out about it.
I just made a premiere room and then I disappeared.
Hey, disappeared!
And then I reappeared right now and just got fast set up.
But I always want, like, I always love streaming for you guys.
Even though, like, I know, like, it might have been better to just wait until I'm back home.
I still wanted to, like, keep you guys company.
And I did take a lot of breaks this year.
Like, and I feel like, I don't want to take another break.
I don't want to take another break.
I want to stream.
I want to talk to you guys.
I don't want to do...
I don't care if I don't have my actual setup.
I want to stream it and everything.
Powerball, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for your hard work.
I'll definitely visit AX to celebrate your birthday.
I'm so excited.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, I really appreciate it, guys.
I really appreciate you guys traveling to Anime Expo to watch this, um, but yeah, um, what else, what else?
I wrote, like, stuff.
Oh, I went to, I went to an arcade, um, recently, during my travels, and, um, um, I won, you know, like, those creating games and stuff, so they actually, so one of the arcades I went to, uh, they imported, like, uh, the, um, actually not rigged, not rigged,
uh, hand, hand cranes, or UFO catchers, so I actually, I'm coming back with some plushies, too.
I brought, I was like, I knew bringing an empty suitcase was the right, I have one suitcase, guys, that's not, I only, I only have one suitcase, and it's, like, literally, it had, like, almost nothing in it.
All I had, did was, like, I brought, like, um, um, I brought, like, uh, my clothes, and, like, my life, my streaming setup, and it was, like, so empty.
Like, it was like those giant suitcases, too.
Like, those, like, the ones that are, like, up to more than half your height.
And then, so, like, I was like, that's my only suitcase!
And I'm like, thank God!
Thank God I brought this big suitcase for a reason!
And it's for plushies!
Always for plushies!
Yeah!
So, um, so yeah, that was nice!
It was a nice experience!
What else?
I wrote, like, stuff I want to talk about.
Oh yeah!
Also, is the BGM better now?
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Oh!
Speaking... Oh yeah!
And then, like, I actually wanted to do Super Mario-mon while, um, I wanted to do Super Mario-mon while I was, like, you know, traveling.
And I was so fucking stupid.
Because I didn't realize the save file was saved on a different location.
All I did was like... I was like, okay, I got the emulator.
And then I got the Super Mario Mon game.
And then I save both of that in my external hard drive.
I boot it up.
And I was like, New game?
What do you mean?
New game.
Where's my save file?
Where could it be?
And I googled, I was like, where is save file?
And they're like, it's in a different location.
And I'm like, what do you mean it's in a different location?
Yeah, so don't worry.
By the time I'll be back for Super Mario Mon at home.
So do not worry.
I will be back at home by the time I play Super Mario Mon.
By the time I play Super Mario Mon, I will be able to play on the actual save.
File, so I will be back in time.
I made sure of that.
I was like, looking through my schedule, I was like, oh, fuck, okay.
I was so upset.
I was like, no, this might have been the perfect time.
Okay, if I actually had my save file for Super Mario Mon, my entire week would just be Super Mario Mon.
We won't be playing Delta Room.
We won't be playing Nice Day for Fishing, huh?
We'd just be playing Super Mario Mon, because at least I could get that game done.
While I'm, while I'm out here fucking traveling.
Like, I brought a fucking... I brought an Xbox controller for no reason.
I'm, I'm like, I'm like, to be fair, my suitcase was big enough to fit the Xbox controller.
But I'm like, I didn't need to bring my Xbox controller.
I...
I could have used this boy!
Mario!
We, we don't get toot, boys!
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, sounding more insane by the second.
Um, um, why you sound like you're in church, cause I need to atone for my sins.
I'm actually at, I'm actually at the Vatican City, because I've sinned too much, that I need to, I need to see the new Pope to forgive me.
Where is Doki Bird San Diego in Vatican City?
Right, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Toad voice is getting scarily accurate.
Um, oh yeah, for those who are wondering, I did not apply for Sage Imsdam.
Uh, I know some people are like, oh my god, no I did not, I, I did not, I'm, I'm way too busy.
I, I, I, I'm also like, I will, I honestly, I would only do Sage Imsdam again, if Kony was there.
Um, because like, I want Team Brawl Pope back, like, yeah!
I heard Kony wasn't doing it, I, I wasn't doing it too, so, also I found, like, I saw that they were saying like, um, there were so many people returning too.
Like, 30 plus people, uh, signed up for, um, so, 30 plus, 30 plus, 30 plus ex, uh, Sage Imsdam players were coming back for it.
So like, I don't know, I honestly, I also don't want to take a spot from someone who's new.
Because like, what makes these competitions more fun is to see like, new faces in general.
Um, and I think that's what makes the competition more fun.
Because you get to see new interactions, and, um, new participants, and like, uh, meet new people and stuff like that.
So like, also, I didn't want to take a spot because there's so many like, uh, people coming back.
Yeah, but there were 600 entries, but when, if you're a person that want to return to Sage Imslam, you get a guaranteed spot.
Um, uh, you get a guaranteed spot for the next Sage Imslam if you're a return player, from what I'm told.
Um, so if you want to come back, you, you will, you can, basically.
Like, uh, Sage Ims usually doesn't turn people away if you want to do it again.
Um, I heard that he, maybe they're, I don't know, I saw on Twitter, Sage Ims was saying how they're, he's inviting, making more teams for it, to accommodate for the newer players.
Um, yeah, I assume like, because like, you know, they're, they're coming back, so you know how they work and stuff like that.
Uh, uh, but yeah, so I also want to give a spot for like, newer players to join in and stuff like that.
Because, y'know, I've already done 2 Sage Ims slams.
Um, I already made, I dunno, I w, I feel like I already made an impact on Zangief, and I already made an impact on King!
So like, I feel like I'm, I don't know, for some reason I don't know how, I m, how, like, me on Zangief made such an impact on Street Fighter.
I HAHAHAI!
I didn't know what the fuck I was doing!
Um!
HAHAHAHA!!!
So like, I don't, I feel like, I don't know, I feel like I don't think I could ever outmatch whatever, um, outmatch whatever the fuck I did on Zangief there.
Like, I don't think I could ever top what I fucking did when I was on Zangief, like, like, everyone actually trained to, like, everyone tried to train against me and learned, like, all how to counter me and everything.
It was crazy.
I was like, oh my god, what the fuck?
Bro, I'm so tired.
Like, because I skipped, I literally skipped one day of training.
I skipped one day because I was going fucking crazy.
Like, you guys don't understand.
I was going fucking crazy with all these practices.
And I skipped one day of practice because I needed a break.
I could not do, I could not play more.
And it was over for me.
They, like, learned so much just to counter me.
Just because, like, um, it's because I was, like, what, undefeated, right?
I, I, like, not, I, was I undefeated?
I remember, or I lost, like, one game or some shit, um, during, like, one of the rounds or something.
And then during, yeah, and then they all, like, studied me after that.
Like, like,
yeah, yeah, yeah, I went undefeated on the second day.
And then I, everyone just studied what I did and everything to the point.
And then I, and then I skipped one day, one fucking day of not practicing because I just, I wanted to play something else.
I would have gone crazy.
I would actually have gone insane if I had to play more.
I was so tired.
I was, I was so fucking tired.
I hated it.
That, like, I just, I quit it.
And I think skipping that one day actually, like, cost me because everyone was still fucking practicing.
I, but yeah, I don't, um, I don't, I don't think, uh, Uh, I don't think I could have, I honestly do not think I could have, I could have topped that Zangief performance.
Especially when I heard, especially when I heard that they nerfed the fuck out of Zangief right after.
I don't, like, Zangief was my boy.
But I don't think I could play anybody else.
Like, because he was the one that you, because he was the one that you played that to tell people.
And, like, I only play characters that, like, honestly, like, like, I want to play characters that would, like, just get you tilted.
Like, I, like, a rage bait character.
Like, I just, I just want to, I want to play characters that are rage baitable.
Like, like, so I feel like, you know, I don't know.
Zangief is just, Zangief and King, it just hits that spot.
Like,
they, they, it just hits, you know?
It just, it's just, it just hits.
And, like, I don't know if I get, if I do Zangief I'm slamming and I don't know if there's a character that just hits like that, you know?
That just gives that same vibe.
That gives the same, like, grapple, like, like, same, oh my, like, when you lose to it and, like, you get hit by one move.
Just all it takes is one move and it, they mentally boom.
And, like, those are the characters I like, because I remember that moment.
Next day, thank you for the super chat that you think, when I was playing King, um, for the Tekken State Jam Slam.
And I was watching VODs of, like, um, of, like, the POVs of the people I fight.
And they're, like, this is bullshit.
This is...
One move!
Takes away so much of my HP!
Just one move!
And, like, that's what makes me happy.
Like, that's honestly, like, and the, like, just one move can make you mental boom.
And, like, I like those types of characters, like, and my loyal fans and the alley kicks.
Like, and yay!
Oh my god.
I still can't believe...
Like, I need, I like to play characters that do that.
Like, the characters that are just fun to, like, fuck around with.
Um, uh...
Let's see.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You mind-breaking Saikuno and 1-in-dangumi was my highlight this time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, and I have zero defense.
Why defend when you can just attack?
Like, that's how I remember.
That's how I played...
That's how I played King and Zanky.
I literally just go attack, attack, attack, attack.
Because why...
Why defend when you can attack?
Why defend when you can grab?
Exactly.
Um...
Forward, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It just hits...
She says, as she air grabs an opponent one foot off the ground.
I just keep...
Thank you for the super chat.
I told you, like...
That's what I live for.
I'm here.
I remember, like...
I saw that clip with Ludwig.
Like, that's what made me follow him, finally, on Twitter.
Um...
But he doesn't follow me back.
But he knows I exist, apparently.
Um...
Where he was, like...
Where he was saying how, like...
I am the one that just wants the cheese.
I don't care about actually learning the game.
I just want to win by sheer cheese.
I just...
I just want to...
I just want to win by cheese and rage bait.
Who cares about actually learning the mechanics and, like, the game itself.
When I can just win the game by doing one or two moves.
Because that's literally how I played King.
I learned one to three...
Like, I learned three moves on King.
And it was alley kick, grab one, and grab two.
And then I mixed in some button mashing in between.
That's literally the three moves I learned.
And then when you do grab one, make sure you do the...
The...
This button...
One button or the second button.
And...
And then on Zangief, it was the same.
I learned four moves on Zangief.
Because apparently you can't button mash in Street Fighter.
And I don't remember those four moves.
I remember.
Grab one and grab two.
And then whatever.
I don't remember the other two.
I don't remember.
Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, and yeehaw.
Yeehaw.
Is this why Dookie's ear is yellow to cheese in all the games?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, that's basically it.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Frame data?
I only know.
Cheese.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, drive impact.
And then drive impact.
Defend?
The fuck is that?
As long as I hit one grab, I need to hit two grabs and he's dead.
Like...
Exactly, I didn't pay $70 to learn how to defend.
Blocking is for fucking cowards.
I know my tier.
I'm in a beginner's tier for a reason.
Beginners don't need to learn how to block.
But yeah, maybe if like...
I don't know.
Maybe Seacham does a new game.
Maybe.
Because like...
I do...
I don't know what the fuck neutral is.
I don't fucking know.
It goes in one ear and out the other.
Like, I don't fucking know.
I don't retain information.
The tournament has been...
Guys, the tournament has been over for like half a year.
It's time...
Of course I didn't retain anything.
I have a...
I have limited hard drive space.
I need to delete things when things are over.
So I can...
I can know new things.
Guys, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
On top of Tekken...
Did you know Bamco replaced the whole Tekken balance scene because last season was a disaster?
Thank you.
It was a Super Chat.
No, I didn't know that.
I don't keep up with fighting games, to be fair.
The times I do keep up...
You know, when it shows up on my Twitter feed or like...
You know...
Yeah, usually like the fighting game stuff is just when they shows up to my Twitter feed.
I don't really keep much up to date about fighting games in general.
I heard about that new...
Well, I saw the new Marvel...
I almost said Marvel Rivals.
I saw that new Marvel fighting game that trailer dropped.
That shit looked so fucking cool.
That shit really...
It looked really, really cool.
Um...
There's something I wanted to talk about, but I forgot.
Ah, fuck.
It was on my mind when I saw that Super Chat.
Ah, what was it?
What was it?
Ah.
Oh, man.
Ah, I'm trying to remember.
I'm trying to remember my limited hard drive space.
See, this is what happens.
I can't believe you guys filled up my hard drive space, guys.
I can't...
No!
I wanted to talk about something that clearly wasn't important, I guess, because I already forgot what it was about.
Yeah, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I fear not the man who practiced 10,000 moves once, but I fear the man who practiced one or four moves 10,000 times.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
No!
My hard drive.
Oh, my God.
What was it?
It was something I wanted to talk about.
Fuck!
Ah!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to think.
I'm trying so hard to think right now.
Was it Tekken related?
Oh, my God.
Aw.
Think.
Think, Doki, think.
God damn it!
Okay, it's something related to video games.
Zahnerman, thank you for the super chat thingy, thank you.
And for some god damn ungodly reasons, Yann does, ever does a Smash Bros, you should pick up Dwarf and put terror into people who can't play against them.
Thank you for the super chat thingy, I'm gonna fucking play Steve, what the fuck?
I'm... Why play Ganondorf when I can play Steve?
Every time I do a move, I can be like Chicken Jockey.
That's the correct thing to do.
He's a band, can't band this, how dare you?
I am for the people, the people wanna see Steve.
Johnny Lacone, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
We need a Brain Expansion slot, fun.
It's really hard to play.
I would learn Steve just because I heard that people do not want it.
I heard Steve is like really tilting to play against.
That's why I feel like Steve is really...
would be, Steve would be the one.
Yes, Sid.
He's tilting and he's top tier.
You will try...
Yeah, but I feel like the...
But I feel like if I learn the base mechanics of Steve, then I can...
And I'm in the beginner division, it's over.
It's over for them all.
I feel like Steve is like the noob destroyer.
He seems like a rage bait.
He seems like something I can use to rage bait people.
I just need to know how to mine and craft.
Minecraft.
God, I wish I remembered what I wanted to talk about.
God fucking damn it.
Fuck.
God, I'm so mad.
Now I'm getting rage baited.
I'm rage baiting myself.
I'm...
Because I'm like, what was it?
What did I want to talk about?
I wanted to tell you guys.
I get rage baited by your own.
It's something related to gaming.
It was like on the topic of fighting games.
And it was on the topic of fighting games and like Tekken.
Because like...
Like that like set off something in my head about something else.
And I don't remember.
Fuck.
Okay, give me it guys.
I'm thinking.
No, I talked...
I just talked about the Marvel fighting game too.
I just talked about it.
I'm thinking.
I'm thinking guys.
Ah, what was it?
Ah...
Like it was something to do with Tekken.
But it wasn't about Tekken.
But it led me to a different topic.
And now I...
It was like...
Ah, it's like those fleeting thoughts that just disappear.
Because...
Because like...
Uh...
No, it wasn't about Armor King.
No.
It wasn't.
Ah, I guess we'll never know.
The one that got away.
Guys.
It could have been a cool topic too.
It could have been such a cool topic.
The one that got away.
Chat.
Yay.
Roku, thank you for the super chat link.
Thank you.
Uh...
Oh no.
Yeah, I know about the new Marvel fighting.
We were watching...
Um...
We were watching the state of play today.
This morning.
So...
It was really interesting.
There was a lot of interesting games.
Um...
I'm looking forward to the James Bond game.
And...
Um...
I guess that's...
Hmm...
I mean, all the other games were already announced and stuff.
So...
Oh, I want to play Jump Force.
I...
Someone...
Jump Force is actually a game I really want to play.
Oh!
Oh, I remember.
I remember.
Because Capcom contacted me.
After I played Onimusha.
Because I think I was like, you know, the...
One of the few streamers that were actually streaming Onimusha.
But Capcom contacted me.
And they wanted to send me a Onimusha merch package.
And everything.
So I was like, yay!
Because I think I'm like, one of the ten people that actually stream Onimusha.
But I love Onimusha!
Like, I don't know.
I wish...
I wish Onimusha was more popular.
Because it is such a good game.
It's so camp...
Like, the voice acting...
For two is so fucking ridiculous.
I legitimately did not remember much of two.
It's like, sand land all over again.
Yay!
But it's like, actually, it's so campy.
And I love the voice acting.
And like, the what the fuck that's...
What the fuck shit that's going on.
In Onimusha 2.
Onimusha 1 was not like this.
I...
I think Onimusha 1 reminded me more of Devil May Cry.
Um, but Onimusha 2 was like, what if we just add a metal horse?
Like, what if...
What if...
A metal horse and then, like, Mr. Nimbus?
Um...
He he he!
The random robot horse.
Out of fucking nowhere.
And a metal fish.
Um...
But yeah, they're sending me a little care package.
Uh, for their merch though.
Because they enjoyed the stream.
And I'm like, yippee!
I love Capcom!
Yay!
And they were really nice about it.
They're like, oh, we want to send you a little merch kit.
And everything.
And like, um...
It has like a jack...
I don't know what's in it.
I just know it has a jacket.
I...
I have so many jackets now.
I am from like, different games.
I have like, Monster Hunter jacket.
I have a Monster Hunter jacket.
I have like, Wukon jackets.
And I have an Onimusha jacket.
Like, I have so many fucking jackets from so many different games.
I don't have to buy clothes anymore.
I actually don't.
I...
That's the best part.
Like, I love being content creator.
Because I don't have to buy clothes anymore.
I just...
If you send me free shit, I just...
I guess I'll just wear it in line.
Yay!
I don't need to...
I don't need to buy clothes anymore.
I just need to buy pajamas.
Oh yeah, speaking of pajamas...
Um...
The...
Uh...
The Gina and Draws collab...
Pajama set is...
I'm a walking ad.
Hey!
It was...
Free is free.
Okay?
Um...
Anyway...
What was I...
Uh...
What was I, uh, what was I saying?
Uh... Ah, fuck.
Uh, free.
How expensive is your... But, yeah, anyway.
Uh... Yeah, free is my favorite word, guys.
Uh... But, yeah, the pajamas are coming in now.
I saw some people taking photos of it and everything already.
We tweeted some.
But it looks really comfy!
It looks really comfy.
I love the sleep masks, too.
So I'm glad.
I hope people are...
Um, apparently all the shipment... Everything has been shipped now.
Um... So, and, like, uh... So I hope you guys get them soon and everything.
Um... But, yeah, I'm really excited.
Uh... I'm really, really excited about, uh... All the new stuff that's coming in and everything.
Oh, my God.
I'm so... Uh... Busy, busy, busy, busy.
After this stream, I have to go back to work.
Go back to concert stuff.
And, um... Back to concert prep stuff.
And also, like, other things.
Like, you know, my actual birthday stream and stuff like that.
Um... Ugh... Just a lot of things going on behind the scenes.
Um... But, yeah.
I think that's really all I want to talk about today.
I'm sorry it was, like, such a short stream today.
Um... But, uh... Since I'm traveling, I can't really do, like, super long streams.
I'll try and do, like, a two-hour...
What?
Two-hour Deltarune stream tomorrow.
Um... Wait, it's Deltarune, right?
At least two hours tomorrow.
We'll see if we can finish chapter one tomorrow.
Um... Even though I'm replaying chapter one.
Um...
Let's see if we can finish chapter one.
And then, like, you know, the second part next week, we'll do more...
More and more, um... Longer Deltarune playthrough when I have my own setup again.
But I hope you guys enjoyed, uh... Hearing me yap for an hour today.
Um... The time... I was... I did stream on Twitch for an hour as well.
So, technically, it's a two-hour stream.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
It was a great time hanging out with my dragoons, as always.
Um... I hope you guys enjoy, um... Um... Like, hanging out with me.
Even though, um... The setup is... It's a little scuffed.
Um... But you guys refilled your dokium.
As next you say, thank you guys for the superchat.
Thank you.
Matty, thank you for the superchat.
That you sent treats for it.
Yes!
I did!
I retweeted something!
Thank you guys so much!
Oh, yes.
Dad is at a new sitter.
Uh... A newer sitter this time.
Because my usual sitter can't, uh... Take care of Dad.
Uh... So then we're trying a new sitter.
And, like, uh... She's been, like, sending me pictures and videos of, uh...
So, oh yes, by the way, I gave her like a bar collar, but it has no battery because I got worried that... Okay, so this is dad's new thing that he likes to do.
He tries to trick me into feeding... Okay, so... Oh wait, that's not new, but he's been realizing that sometimes it works because sometimes I'm really, really tired.
So he's been tricking people.
He's been trying to trick me into feeding him early in the morning.
So I got worried for my new city because I'm like, worried because like, you know, she could be an easy mark for him that... So, so I was worried and like, apparently she lives with roommates and obviously I didn't want to, you know, inter... like, yeah,
I didn't want to like, like, make it bad.
Like, you know, that you have to sleep and stuff.
So, so, so I was like, here is his bar collar.
Like, like, that has no battery in it, but when he sees it, he'll understand.
Like, he'll be like, oh, fuck.
Like, because he doesn't want to risk it actually being on.
So like, so like, every time I use the bar collar, because it hasn't, I haven't used that in like years.
So like, he hasn't had, he... I've only used it when he was, uh, when we were training him.
When we first, not when, not like when he got older and he realized that like, barking lets him get things.
And then that's when I was like, okay, so it's like, like PTSD.
So, um, so like, I've only used it for like, during like, that short moment of his life.
Like, but he knows, every time I bring it up, he knows.
Like, and he like listens.
Like, the conditioning lives on.
So like, it's been years since that bar collar has ever had battery in it.
But like, it's still, he knows.
He actually knows what it does.
So he doesn't want to risk it actually ever being on.
And so, he, he doesn't want to risk it.
So I gave it, like, I gave it to her just in case.
Like, just in case, dad was like, she's easy, Mark.
She doesn't know.
She doesn't know my actual schedule.
She's new.
So I was like, if he ever wakes you up at six in the morning,
just, just show him this and he'll be, he will go back to his bed.
So, um, so yeah, I do get like, photo updates ever so often.
Um, just ruin his whole operation.
Um, and like, you know, told her like, the medication, like what he needs for his medication and everything.
Um, and, um, also, yes.
Oh my gosh.
Someone says overstuffed wiener dog.
Okay, wiener dogs come in either two sizes.
Fit as fuck or, or fat as fuck.
That is luckily not.
It's also one reason why, like, so many wiener dogs also have, like, um, back problems too.
Because they're just, they're just like, they're, like, dad, thankfully, is a fit wiener dog.
Um, the dude, he's, yeah, ripped her fat fuck.
Like, it's one or two.
And I do not want dad to be a, to be a fat fuck.
Because I want, because, okay, the reason why I'm not, I'm not fat shaming him.
But, it actually fucks with the, with, with like, the ankles.
Because they're short, you know?
They're really short.
So, like, there's not a lot of muscle on their legs.
You know?
And, like, he's already broke his back.
I am not putting more trauma onto him.
I, I'm not.
They're really tired.
Like, their legs are not that long.
They cannot hold up so much weight.
Like, yeah.
So, I'm trying to make sure he continues to say, ripped ass fuck.
He is gonna be a grandpa dog.
A grandpa.
He will age to be a grandpa wiener dog.
And he's still gonna be, like, those ripped ass fuck grandpas.
Like, you know, those ripped, like, those, like, um, those grandpas.
Those, like, grandpas that somehow have six packs and all that muscles.
He will be that grandpa.
Okay, guys?
I cannot.
I need his legs to keep on working.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
Anyway, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, I still don't forgot.
I still forgot to do an ending stream.
So, I'm just gonna put the starting screen in there.
I'll have the ending stream tomorrow.
I just, I knew I forgot something.
I spent so much setting this up.
Like, setting up this little vacation spot when I'm not on an actual vacation.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye.